it's like a tip it's a weather map
I got a storms coming in category
seven
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Paul Rudd he's an
actor writer and producer has been in
some of the most beloved films and TV
shows over the last 25 years from Judd
Apatow comedies to the Marvel Universe
and you can catch him on the new Netflix
comedy living with yourself which is set
to release on October 18th Paul Rudd
welcome to the show thank you very much
Sean I'm excited to be here how are you
feeling going into this are you a spicy
food dude
I like spicy food you know you know I
don't shy away from it I'm not so crazy
about plutonium and I know that's where
some of this is headed so I guess we'll
see
[Music]
[Music]
of cauliflower going shout out to the
veggies get you efficient out here all
right
[Music]
as we mentioned in your intro you have
this Netflix comedy living with yourself
where you played two versions of the
same character what were the challenges
and shooting scenes with yourself and
then did you gain any sympathy for the
co-stars that you've had over the years
the challenges with playing two parts in
the way that we did it there's many
different ways you can do it I would
record the lines for both characters and
then I had a thing in my ear and I would
act as one character and then the
response was a guy off the side you know
hitting a button for the reply and then
I would flip around and remember where I
was standing where I was looking and and
then just act opposite to the sound I
read a quote of yours recently that I
thought was really interesting where you
said that a lot of the movies you find
funniest are categorized as dramas and
then that some of the most dramatic
things happen in comedies mm-hmm I mean
I think it's a pretty wide spectrum but
I really I mean some of my favorite
movies one of the funniest movies uh for
me of all time is this movie with nail
at I British movie and from 80s which is
essentially a very sad film but whenever
I see somebody that's experiencing
something heartbreaking or it's some
kind of struggle or some kind of
emotional something rather and the way
they deal with it is through humor there
are many levels I fight and then I find
that really funny but I also find it
relatable and I think that that's when
something can be funny but then
incredibly moving and heartbreaking at
the same time Alan Partridge or the
office I thought you know that that kind
of comedy or is is funny but it's
actually also kind of sad
can I ask you some questions whatever
you want because I think that you are
the most fascinating character within
this setup how many of these have you
done I think you're number 166 okay
that's really impressive
thank you do you feel differently now
than you did when you first started does
it affect you physically yeah you know I
think what happens when I first started
it was like a physical adjustment to do
this right and then I think I had a nice
couple seasons there where I was just
cruising I was just on cruise control
I find lately now I'm once again
climbing up the hill like I'm once again
challenged by the sauces you know I
think maybe the maybe the wheels are
coming off the wagon or something you're
an athlete you're pro athlete that's
true hey this is a short window right
I'm impressed with your
stick-to-itiveness I put a lot of city
miles on it you know I don't want to see
what's going on underneath that skin so
Chris Schoenberger who you met when you
came in here he has a relationship with
Britishness that mirrors yours almost
exactly so when he was growing up he
does it family in London you would get
copies of the Beano from his cousins he
would raid tuckshops and try to get
crunchy bars yeah even did a three-month
stint at Oxford right on wow that's
crazy
growing up with tea and crumpets and
Sunday roast and Yorkshire pudding and
all of that it's all my favorite stuff
and it's all very comforting to me
because it's I've just always grown up
with that and it and I and I knew that
like my next-door neighbours weren't
having Yorkshire pudding I knew that I
was like this is weird I didn't know it
was different right that a lot of people
I guess in Kansas City not making
Yorkshire pudding this happen I'm gonna
hit you with five please biscuits Oh
hockey with five British biscuits you
rank them from best to worst okay mam
custard cream mm-hmm McVitie's chocolate
digestive jammie Dodgers Cadbury fingers
and jaffa cakes oh man of those my
favorite would be the McVitie's the
child I just yeah and it's probably a
toss-up between that in the Cadbury
fingers as a kid the Cadbury fingers are
perfect right they're great
bourbon creams what was the first one
that used to consecrate yeah those are
great too I really like those
many people have jack jaffa cakes me not
as much
I don't want fruit in my biscuit okay so
that's in the physical jelly yeah yeah
there's because the one no the other one
which was the we have the jammie Dodgers
jammie Dodgers I never he did jammie
Dodgers I am I'm not even so sure I know
what jammie Dodgers are and there be
probably people that are British saying
well you just lost your passport
[Music]
pineapple heart beat don't feel the
pressure to eat all of them and I'm
worried that way I was all set to go
with the I know we're gonna do the wings
gonna scared eaten because I wouldn't be
eating all this I wouldn't go full bill
burr so when will ferrell was on the
bill simmons podcast he said that the
original script for anchorman was
actually a survival story where a Plane
full of newsmen Clips another plane
that's just full of monkeys and Chinese
throwing stars and then basically you
guys had to survive on this mountain
yeah well orangutangs take you guys out
one by one that's right
news men versus apes I was gonna ask do
you know anything about that I thought
he was just goofing around no that's
absolutely true I heard about it it was
already nixed before it got greenlit at
the studio because I think somewhere
somewhere pretty early on they realized
that's impossible I think the idea was
all these newsmen were flying over to
some news convention or something and
they're all smoking some e-cigarettes
that the whole cabin filled up with
smoke and the plane crashed now of
course the plane was also transporting
Chinese throwing stars and lots of
martial arts weapon and it crashes on an
island inhabited by Apes and and then it
just turns into a servile tell newsmen
versus Apes which I want to see that
when I was sick what could have been
yeah is it true that when you were
shooting what hot American summer that
you guys actually stayed on the campsite
and slept in the bunks yeah we it was
it was this camp called Towanda and
hones Dale Pennsylvania it was a
functioning camp we actually had to shut
down production for a week almost a week
because in the middle of it some kid was
coming to celebrate his bar mitzvah at
the camp so you're on the clock yeah
that's how that's how high-level our
production was we had to stop in the
middle to let the camp take a hit like
this kid rented it out for his Bar
Mitzvah what do you make of the ant man
kills Thanos by crawling up his butt
meme I consider it a lost opportunity
[Music]
are you from Chicago originally right
that's restarted here thanks honey sorry
are you a sports fan II like bears I do
I love the Bears I'm a White Sox fan I
like the Bulls yep I mean I grew up in
the North suburbs but for whatever
reason I became a Sox fan mm-hmm but
that is a lovely segue I love when that
happens cuz I want to take a wig to talk
about the big slick weekend an annual
event you co-founded to help raise money
for the Cancer Center at Children's
Mercy yeah in the ten years you guys
have been doing the celebrity softball
game what do you think is your crowning
athletic achievement there is one time a
couple years ago where I I think I
scored all three outs in the inning Wow
everything else outside of that is just
a disaster I don't think that record
will be broken do you do you know one
time we did it I got to this we were
taking batting practice and I got to
Jeremy Guthrie who was a pitcher for the
Royals until I said do you want to see
what it's like to actually stand in the
box with a major league pitcher I said
yeah and he had pitched the night before
but he was still throwing about 8590
miles per hour and it's impossible it is
so hard and that's just a straight
fastball if he starts mixing stuff in
yeah that was just I knew is coming and
it's it's imparting a bullet
[Music]
whoo beautiful cauliflower piece I was
gonna say that looked like a softball
that you just put in your mouth
feels like that I don't
almost harder the sauce or the whole
thing this really is a turning point and
then that was looks like a dinosaur egg
that was like yeah you're not supposed
to do that yours
you didn't pieces there's no wrong way
Paul you're doing great I'm pretty sure
there's a wrong way and I think that was
it
I probably every Korean segment on our
show called explain that Graham we do a
deep dive and I guess Instagram which is
impossible for you because you have no
social media to speak of we have a
workaround we're gonna pull some photos
of you with famous musicians so I'll
show you the picture and then you just
tell me the backstory does that sound
good yeah all right first up its you
sitting courtside at MSG alongside 50
cent you guys get a chance to chat at
all during the game yeah he was super
nice really cool by the way Howard Stern
sitting right next to 50 cent - yes yeah
he was great
he took a picture with my son he just
happened to be sitting next to me he was
really friendly and then actually months
later I was on a flight and he was on
the flight and and then we kind of said
hey how's it going how are you and and
then he gave me a pair of headphones Wow
alone all right up next do you have a
favorite behind-the-scenes memory from
this music video sketch alongside
Beyonce and Justin Timberlake
I remember one of it when we taped it or
we did it and and Timberlake walked on
and how insane everybody went and I and
I had those moments I've had this
throughout my career where sometimes I
just take I remind myself to step out of
it and look at what's happening here I'm
doing this with Beyonce and Justin
Timberlake
and the other two guys I knew so it was
I and a huge fan of but I was like I've
never met these two well you know what
they say we got to do this with Paul
Rudd no that's what this nobody says
that so whenever I get asked questions
about hot ones I always find myself
delivering these parables over and over
which I find when I do it perhaps some
of the nuances lost and you're somebody
who's been doing press around TV and
film for 25 years do you ever think
about how much your narrative is shaped
by the need to package the details of
your life into these instantly
accessible anecdotes ice a great
question oh really
yeah after a while you get used to
answering the same questions so you just
kind of think of it differently to say
the same answer and at a certain point I
don't know whether or not that is the
way it happened if that's really true or
it's just I've answered that question so
many times that it's now the truth or
the way I feel about it
many people have asked me about how to
get started what was and I used to love
those Steve Martin comedy records when I
was a kid and nothing like would maybe I
want to do this for a living because of
those that was a kind of the first time
I've said that so many times in
interviews I think it's true it might
not be true but I it's such a limited
window you have a few minutes to talk
about and then it's just that becomes
the default answer and then late night
it's its own beast because then there's
this implicit expectation to perform
yeah is someone with stage experience
are you more comfortable in a setting
like that than say like a film junket no
they're all those those things are
always nerve-wracking
and and there I think I learned at an
early age that is all artificial you
know as a kid I would watch Letterman
and me like my godness is amazing I mean
it was amazing and he is amazing and I
but I think like so cool like friends
coming over and sitting on the couch it
was later on I realized oh they're
promoting something like they're selling
this is all there's a machine going on
and and and some of that commercialism I
was like as I started to do that
and knowing that part of the job has
become selling things and and there are
some things that are really fun to do
like I was very excited to do this and I
excited to have you and thank you and I
and there are shows that I like and I
also have a thing where I just can't
answer anything serious it which is
perfect in this setting yeah absolutely
and then on the topic of Dave I know
that you joined to fan clubs in your
life Scottish music duo The Proclaimers
and David Letterman do you remember how
you became one of Dave's disciples and
what do you think is his strongest
quality as a entertainer
I think the David Letterman is a single
hand like responsible for the
sensibility and sense of humor of this
country in a way it doesn't quite even
get the credit he has credit and respect
and everything but I think he's such an
important figure especially in early
honest and alasa but this says he didn't
want to really be there yeah you know I
always think about that you know there
was a time where I think that he was
like competing with Leno and then like
there was a time or maybe he like left
his took his foot off the gas but to me
he was funnier then yeah and the thing
that he has that I find really appealing
is he's got such a massive intellect
that his disdain for all of the showbiz
and all of the just nonsense that comes
along with it he is so in its right
place that I just
and just don't think there's anybody
better this is a big this is a big big
you and me both right here they're like
[Music]
good lord
our canoes Pro the bravado Spice Company
we're just one land on the Scoville
meter around 100k on this one okay
does it taste that way yeah make sure
when Larry King asked judd apatow to
talk about something about paul rudd
that no one else knows he says that you
do this thing when you take pictures of
celebrities you do this thing with your
hand where you make it look like there's
a butt hovering over them yeah how do
you if I gave you my phone can you show
me how you do that sure like just the
open up the camera yeah
so if I do this and I get you in hand
and I get my hand going here
[Music]
so that looks like you study behind a
guy or a girl
that's totally naked there are things
you can do
where'd you learn this skill no no but
I'm glad I did
[Music]
now yeah okay so that one's that one's
definitely a guy whoa you got a bull
sack yeah after a while you start you
can yeah great expanding growing I
learned uh my pinky at the right angle
this makes a great scrotum wait a minute
you got more oh do I have them work this
is when you're probably gonna be able to
show on the show we'll give it a shot
you know what you can always we'll run
it by Randy yeah you can always open
this picture up when you're on the
subway that's a little a little blurry
but you know you can - you gonna she's
OOP Jim in on the ya know that was gross
I have thousands of those pictures of
people that you would not expect to see
in those photos that are pretty good
[Music]
lips are really tingling well if you
think they're tingling now this is the
bomb and I should tell you it comes from
Kansas City I'm not sure if that's a
point of pride necessarily mm-hmm I'll
let you be the judge of that
Kansas City huh mm-hmm
Holman they make de bomb they make
dabomb dabomb is the one
[Music]
I don't touch this button I've noticed
yeah
[Music]
shoutout Kansas City shoutout Kansas
City Wow
yeah we also have Patrick mahomes don't
judge us Justin
[Music]
so I'm the topic of Kansas City I know
that you're a barbecue loving Kansas
City boy what makes the z-man sandwich
from Joe's KC the best sandwich in the
world oh my god it's just there's
something there's something about it
that is it's perfect it's a perfect
sandwich the right levels of meat I'm
actually not a vegetarian but I'm trying
to become better at should point that
out because there is meat in this
sandwich but its own it's the right
ratio of brisket
they put provolone cheese on it it's
good cheese with onion rings and
original Joe's sauce it's incredible and
just the combination that with the
seasoned fries maybe a tank seven on the
side and you got yourself oh that's a
perfect meal as someone who ranked in
state on his competitive forensics team
in high school
what's your refutation to those who say
that Texas barbecue is better than
Kansas City barbecue there's a real
rivalry and then there will be some in
Tennessee that say hey but come on but
come on why you guys argue about your
nonsense
we're the ones so I don't claim but I
know Kansas City barbecue it's the best
I would also like to find another NFL
stadium that smells so good tailgating
United nicest smelling parking lot in
the NFL that's what they say that's
right now some of the people that are
there at the game I'm not I wouldn't I
wouldn't put my money down no I'll call
Camaro head for nothing
have you mastered the art of cooking on
your boating re an egg and that big
green egg yet no I know I haven't
mastered it I love it is it just
collecting dust in the backyard no I
really tried this summer I really tried
to really get it my my kids would make
fun of me because I was watching
YouTube videos of like people making
stuff on a green egg I had I bought all
of it accessories
they're called accessories is there
anything that screams middle aged like
this yeah I need a sec tiny you need I
see why people take a second and walk
around well feel free to you can always
take a lab no we're locked in locked in
vain touching that people always used to
say in the 50s and 60s like all we
smoked his cigarettes we didn't know
they were bad for us and as a kid I
would say like come on like how could
you how could you not know I feel the
same way about the bomb you try that and
right away you know you know that's not
good for you yeah yeah you wanna see
what's happening at Gotti what so heads
guys cats get this whole sides turning
pink yellow it's like a tip is it's a
weather map because storms coming in
category seven
how about let you down because I haven't
gone for that no if anything you're
setting a really high bar whatever
reason you know people are people get
really hyped when someone makes it
through with no water no milk great
it was rarefied air alright you and like
Tali Barry and Guy Fieri say it again
it is Viet II do you think it's Fieri
well probably not I think if you were
talking to him and you said Fieri he'd
correct you and safe Yeti oh [ __ ] that
guy then it's quite an intro you got fee
Eddie right Dave them all the time again
did they get it wrong every time you
knocked it out of the park man which was
a more memorable experience joining an
all Cantonese cast for Gen X cops to or
appearing in that apocalyptic Super
Nintendo commercial in the early 90s
alright was it was a question well they
were both memorable because they both
you know changed the world as we know it
shooting with an all Cantonese cast in
Hong Kong and this Jackie Chan produced
sequel to Gen X cops was spectacularly
weird I'm playing the head of the FBI
they want to bleach my hair blonde and I
have to go after a robot nothing about
this screamed quality in any way yeah oh
absolutely
no I want to go to Hong Kong for two
months that's a nice second
I want to go to Hong Kong for two months
and see what this is all about and it
was great they were great city was
this is great alright this is yours what
if we put a little of every single one
yeah let's try this is is this gonna put
me in the hospital what are you gonna do
you just show you right now I know what
you're doing this the smart way yeah
you're torn I'll make it a little hot
sauce puddle look at us
Hey look at this look at us huh who
would have thought not me maybe these
are props okay got that one de bomb for
Kansas City from Kansas City
[Music]
can i brothers/sisters
I do have a younger brother named Gavin
what does Gavin do he actually works on
the show he does yeah
and then um here we are now 166 episodes
later doing in all 10 sauces dab on the
cauliflower wings I'd like to point out
yours as much neater than mine that's
falling off the board I like it looks
like an abstract painting well you want
to see an abstract painting uh but
Jackson Pollock oh yeah when we're done
shooting this segment hey I must say
though it's a great idea it's a great
construct for an interview thank you but
I think you're an excellent interview oh
thank you didn't even need the hot sauce
I appreciate that but you know if you
got it you got it you got it and you got
hey are you so I'm running if you run it
through like a that's that's a lot
that's a lot that's a that's a fully
coated nice all right there dump this is
very stupid but I would point out it was
your idea Paul so so to be in sick the
rest of the day
all right
[Music]
breathe in through your mouth so yeah
it's like reading in dry yes exactly can
you make you cry yeah well yeah I'll
probably I'm just I'm shedding I'm
watering up quite a bit actually do the
scene right now oh god I didn't make the
seventh grade basketball team
okay so Brett made it Pat made it am I
not good enough you're killing me
breaking my heart it's not the hot sauce
it's you you are good enough you should
have made that team you know what I'm
gonna practice harder I'm gonna work on
my jumper I'm gonna work on my ball
handling and you know what what next
year I'm gonna be on that roster yeah
you are yeah you know why you are good
enough
you are talented enough you're strong
enough and Zi ball rod yeah what is it
look at you ten cauliflower vegan wings
up ten cauliflower vegan wings down this
camera this camera this camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your life I got nothing going on careful
around your eyes yeah that was another
mistake the finger might have not been
the smartest you know what it was good
for the scene yeah oh yeah we don't need
again the artificiality of the car I'm
not gonna sell anything I'm here to
celebrate this is a celebration
commercial hey what's going on hot ones
fans this is Sean Evans checking in and
do you smell that fall it's in the air
no I'm not talking about pumpkin spice
I'm not talking about candy corn I am
talking about the last dab xxx because
the pepper axe harvest it's in baby this
is the hottest hot sauce that we've ever
made with three kinds of pepper axe I'm
talking chocolate X I'm talking mustard
X I'm talking peach X the last dab xxx
it's available now at Heaton Escom Heat
miss calm to order the hottest hot sauce
that we've ever made
wha-wha why is he shaking that bottle
[Music]